là où ça bouge à l'espace culturel de
saint lô pour une sortie d'atelier des
muscles des corps nus des boxeur sur le
ring des femmes en petite tenue
ça sent la sueur l'adrénaline et la
poésie neuf artistes et dix élèves du
collectif art plume exposent ensemble
à chacun son style et son histoire tout
droit sortis de l'atelier dans les
musées les richesses artistiques il est
une jolie femme nue qui sont en jeu par
des hommes et je veux j'ai fait des
hommes nus à 2 par des femmes
bah
une recherche sur l'humain beaucoup sur
les matériaux naturels
je vais travailler autour de la
représentation des trois singes qui en
chine représente la sagesse et de l'avs
se met vite l'idée de faire une série
sur la perte de sens car au bout du
compte ne rien dire ne rien voir ne rien
entendre
c'est une perte de sens qu'on s'inflige
mais qu'est ce qui se passe quand ce
sont les autres qui nous l'affligent
alors nicolas que meurt vous êtes
invités d'honneur de cette sortie
d'atelier
qu'est-ce que vous avez cherché à
montrer là aujourd'hui c'est j'ai
proposé une série sur mars et vénus qui
sont depuis qu'ils sont c'est un terme
est assez récurrent dans mon travail
depuis le début ça me permet de mettre
également une vue de la mère qui est un
des attributs de vénus qua non ils sont
ni chronographie et souvent les
personnages c'était un peu d'aidé des
bagarreurs aussi ou des guerriers alors
ça m'a suivi les femmes les jolies
femmes c'est venu après quand j'étais
petit je fais pas trop comment les faire
bon voilà c'est bien peu après les
sorties d'ateliers c'est jusqu'au 24
décembre au centre culturel de saint lô
pour admirer les oeuvres ou en acheter
une pour noël quant à l'auteur de ce
très beau poisson à la vapeur ses
marques du para et on va aller tout de
suite le retrouver à donville les bains
dans son atelier willy's moi je suis à
l'atelier ici avec marc du parent n'a
pas besoin de masque en fait pour
travailler sur la plaque vous travaillez
en évidence avec c'est quoi la technique
découpage plasma il avait pas que je
fasse un arc électrique avec de les
repousser
c'est une découpe qui est très précise
très fines comme de la dentelle on
enlève on nous fait un trait qui fait à
peine 1 mm donc c'est un avantage
ce canton travaillent sur des tôles fine
c'est que le plasma ne chauffe presque
pas la tôle et on n'a pas de déformation
alors on a vu aussi des objets et des
dons plus en volume la whey +2 en
sculpture comme par exemple comme le
chien là qui à côté nous c'est pas du
tout la même technique on est on est sûr
sur quoi là sur une soudure alors là
c'était plus l'inspiration quand j'ai
commencé à la sculpture alors c'est des
inspirations de césar là c'est
l'inspiration giacometti et césar ratera
beaucoup travaillé sur l'accumulation
donc moi c'est je suis un adepte
du sculpteur césar j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur l'accumulation qu'est-ce
que quand vous dites accueilli mutation
c'est quoi la hausse
voilà on rajoute au fur et à mesure on
rajoute des pièces de métal ça peut être
ça peut être des tiges de fer ça peut
être aussi par exemple de de la
boulonnerie etc et on accumule on
construit on fait une construction en
accumulant les objets quand on voit le
poisson à saint lô c'est encore une
technique différente
c'est une sculpture c'est vrai c'est
vraiment autre chose voilà c'est une
création pure et en même temps toute la
coque extérieure
c'est du découpage de tôle au plasma et
l'intérieur c'est comme un écorché ça
s'appelle le poisson à la vapeur
donc c'est comme un écorché à
l'intérieur on voit tout un circuit de
en cuivre qui est d'inspiration des
bateaux des années 30
vous êtes un [__] fidèles à ce rendez
vous de saint lô de sortie d'atelier les
sorties des ateliers ouverts depuis
combien de temps cette en voilà et sinon
on peut voir vos oeuvres ou alors
j'ai des projets de
l'exposition pour cet été au printemps
je serai aux sept autres gratte au
château drainé ville et puis on a
l'intention de faire la sortie des
jardins cette année dans notre jardin
ici à granville way a donc juste à
donville et où je ferai en même temps
une exposition de sculptures
voilà vous savez tout sur l'atelier de
marque merci nous avoir reçus
je vous en prie avec plaisir
l'orchestré régional de normandie a
rendu hommage à l'un des siens disparu
la semaine dernière thierry tisserand
c'était ce matin en l'église notre dame
de la gloriette deux camps
mais si loin dans une autre vie c'était
sous des couvertures gemini que ce
serait si je suis pas c'est si dur
il revient après trois ans d'absence
nérac en concert ce samedi à travers à
demain